Hulu loves
fans of TV.
So they found Dot and Brie.
with their friends.
They talk TV, so you know what
to stream.
Our guest today is the hilarious, Sherry Cola.
Thank you so much for being here.
Hello, thank you for having me.
I didn't bring a bottle of wine,
but I did bring this personality.
That's okay.
That's all we need.
- Just as good.
- Win, win.
So we're talking about some
of our favorite Comfort TV shows today.
We thought we'd kick it off
with one of our favorite topics.
Delicious dramas.
Double D’s.
You just want to sink your teeth into, you know,
it's like the holidays are going on.
You just want to relax
and turn on something.
You can just veg out on.
That's the bingeability of it.
Bingeability.
I loved that word.
New word. TM.
Absolutely.
I mean, ya’ll are pretty much describing
good trouble which is the show I’m on.
I have to talk about it.
- yes, please.
- I just started it.
I love it.
You're so funny by the way.
Stop. keep going.
- Okay. You're super funny.
- More.
- More.  Adjectives.
- You're really funny.
- I’m blushing.
Wait, no, I'm intrigued.
I want to know what it’s about.
Cause I haven’t seen it.
So in the world of people
in their twenties.
Messy, flawed.
Down town LA.
Fighting for something in their own way.
Everyone has an arc and love triangles.
- Oh.
- love trapezoids.
- Love octagon.
- Good Lord.
- Wow.
Shapes.
Colors, diversity.
Inclusion. Equity.
L.A.
I mean, really, the title is,
you know, named after the late great john
Lewis's beautiful words, you know,
So I think it's a show for everyone.
I do love, though,
because the first episode
you have two sisters
who, like, just graduated from college.
Seeing them deal with,
you know, just what a young woman
going into the corporate world
would deal with, you know.
And it's not even necessarily over
the top cliche of like,
you've got to fight your way to the top,
like they have people on their side
and then they have people
not on their side.
So it's it's refreshing to see that take,
you know?
Exactly. Very well said.
Now that you say that like young woman,
like getting out of college,
going into the workforce.
I watched younger. Who is
about a woman in her forties
pretending to be 26
- to get into the workforce.
- I love, younger.
Well, first of all, Hilary Duff,
I will die for.
I will watch her in absolutely anything.
Anything.
Even that added layer of her
like lying to be younger.
Yeah.
And then like lying
to absolutely everyone.
Having a daughter
who's like, studying abroad.
- Yeah.
- Who wants to come back.
Okay, you guys are selling this for me.
I haven't watched that one yet,
but you guys are making me want to watch.
Know there's nothing
more universal than lying.
Yeah, you know,
and that's what I want to see
the lead character do.
And it's a really interesting twist
that they started with that.
Yeah.
You know,
I mean, that's not a spoiler because it's
literally in the first episode.
Right off the bat.
But she has like such good,
like reasons for it.
Like she's going to have to sell her home.
She wants her second act, you know.
That and she wants like to keep her home
- and stability.
- Yeah.
- Relatable.
- Logistics.
It’s also a drama.
That’s true.
Dramady.
they cry sometimes.
A Croma?
No, I don't hate it.
A Cri-crom.
No.
You know what about reality shows.
You guys into any reality shows lately?
I think for me, what I find
most comforting about reality TV
is just like it's like a just a companion
that's there with me
while I'm free to kind of
do what I need to get done.
- Like I could be on my phone,
- Right,
or if something gets really good
I can stop and watch.
I just like watching other people's
drama for a change.
You know?
I love claim to fame.
What is that? Tell me.
Basically, there's a house of
strangers to each other,
but everyone is related
to an individual celebrity.
So every person has a famous relative.
Then you have the guess who
everyone is related to.
Oh, so it’s like a,
There's like a game show element to it.
You know what I love about
competition series
is that even though
there can only be one winner,
they kind of bond, you know,
and they kind of form
alliances to the point where, well,
you care about this person,
you don't want to throw them
under the bus, but you also want
10 million thousand dollars
for the kids to go to college.
I just started this new show called
Joe Millionaire. Have you heard of it?
That like came back, right?
Yes.
So it's these two guys.
One guy is worth $10 million.
One guy is not.
They get a bunch of girls in the house
and they all are going to be dating
the guys.
But the girls don't know which one is rich
and which one isn't.
So but I think it's interesting
because the guy who's really wealthy,
you know, he's like, Oh, I just want to
meet someone who loves me for me.
And I'm like, But the girls know
that one of you is rich.
So I'm just, that's so interesting to me.
I wonder how that, like,
would you really be able to trust them?
It's 5050.
So all the women are gambling addicts?
Yes, Essentially.
The thing is, I don't think
the other guy's like dirt poor.
It's not like he's never seen
the inside of a salon before.
Like just one guy's worth $10 million
and one guy isn't.
- That's exactly what the host says.
- Fantastic Sam’s.
Oh, and it's this. This butler.
- They're all in a mansion.
- That’s what I was gonna add.
Right this way.
Does anyone go home with the butler?
Oh, well, see, I.
You know, if I was one of the girls.
Yeah.
- Oh, we'll find out.
- You never know.
I'll let you know.
I'll get to the finale and I'll,
I’ll watch as well.
- Yeah, it’s,
- We’ll text.
Personally, I love comedies.
I think the most universal love
language is comedy,
and there's so many good
shows out there right now.
I feel like the Cozy really
is the word because
it's so familiar and so
different from a drama.
Because a drama, you're on the edge of your seat.
You're anxious,
you know what I mean?
You're sweating.
You want answers.
Yeah, but with these sitcoms they exist
just by episode, you could put
on, you know, season three, episode seven,
and you're you're good.
You're not lost.
They really are.
You jump right in.
One of my top ten easily of all time
comedies Bob's Burgers.
I, every,
I don't know what it is,
but every time the theme song starts
and they're all standing out
in front of us, I actually get emotional.
I'm like.
I'm laughing, I'm crying,
I'm sweating, I'm peeing, I'm lactating.
Also, the fact that the kids
never get older, right?
I don't know if that's weirdly comforting.
It's the same thing in
The Simpsons and Family Guy
like and all of those
like true staples of, like animated shows.
Like nobody grows up.
I know I can always go back to them.
- Right
- And they're not going to change
and the stories never get boring.
It's every season
it gets better and better and better.
Yeah, but they're the constant.
Is that too deep?
Not too deep because I want to go deeper.
Cartoons are timeless in that way, right?
Because sometimes the real life
human kids grow too fast.